هي مشاهد تلخص حجم المعاناه التي يعيشها
العشرات من سكان مدينه نيالا جنوب دارفور
شاحنات وسيله اجره في كل مكان
وحقائب تنتظر اصحابها بانتظار الانتقال
الى وجهات قريبه او بعيده اي وجهات فالوضع
هنا لم يعد يطاق انا طبعا استاذ محمد صالح
واحد من سكان المنطقه الذين اختاروا
التوجه الى مدينه الضعين في شرق دارفور
خشيه تعرض عائلته للموت بسبب القصف
المتواصل واملا في الحصول على عمل فللحياه
كلفه لم تعد متوفره في منطقته
[موسيقى]
الاشتباكات التي تدخل يومها الستين خلفت
وراءها عشرات القتلى ومئات الجرحى ووضع
اجتماعيا كارثيا بيوت دمرت متاجر اغلقت
وصيدليات بقيت عاجزه عن توفير الادويه
احنا
زادنا الان يعني قلبنا الشغل فيه وحتى لنا
المركبات حتى توهين يعني الان ما قدروا
يشتغلوها ومع التوصل الاشتباكات وسط
الامال بتوقفها بل تجل ما يتمناه المرء في
نيالا هو مكان ياويه ويقيه ويلات الحرب
فلا امان ممكن اكثر من ذلك